[Music]
a hubble actually looked at the visible
many of those wavelengths all those
wavelengths make it to the surface of
the earth
but
not into the infrared and that's why we
needed a new telescope
and that's what the james webb space
telescope does it it really hones in
on a brand new wavelength regime that we
haven't done much with
so
what intrigues me is when i first
learned of the james webb and how it's
tuned for the infrared the i being
fundamentally a large large-scale
structure guy of the universe i was very
excited to recognize that it will be
able to see the formation of galaxies in
the early universe in a band of light
that is red-shifted into its
into its zone i mean right it's it's
like the universe is as
it's like
put it here universe and then we got you
right right well it's
[Music]
the universe is so balanced and so
perfect it's like no we're in a shooting
gallery oh my goodness
and and so
practically every sort of shooting star
by the way these phrases refer to the
same phenomenon shooting star falling
star
uh meteor right they're all referring to
a
tiny particle
that earth slams into in our orbit
around the sun wow right and we're going
about 18 miles a second
okay
what's that it's like 30 000 kilometers
a second around the sun that's fast and
if you're just minding your business out
there in space and earth slams into you
right the our atmosphere will look like
a brick wall yeah it's like speed yeah
it's kind of like the um
the uh the bug that hits your windshield
you know
that's what these like you know that bug
if that bug if you weren't going 70
miles an hour you know that bug see at
70 miles an hour it's like did that bug
just break my windshield like
[Music]
so you're in space
that's what we want to call that space
now you're
you're not
weightless though people equate
being in space with being weightless
you're only weightless if you're in free
fall uh-huh okay
so if at that moment he cuts off his
engines and they fall
then you're weightless gotcha for as
long as you're falling right okay but
there's a point where the atmosphere
gets thick enough again
and in the case of richard branson's
rocket it was also an airplane it had
airfoil so right as it starts hitting
atmosphere then the control surfaces of
his wings begin to take effect and then
it can actually do a descent as an
airplane but the moment it does that you
are no longer weightless right
okay so i just want to make that clear
the weightlessness is simply for being
in free fall
not for being in what people are calling
space space that's it's not like you hit
space i'm weightless oh my gosh
no no it's are you rockets firing no are
you a plane
no you're just falling you're weightless
over that time it's just like what is it
the parachute drop or whatever it is at
the amusement park
when they just drop the floor out under
you you are weightless until
some parachute opens but over that time
you're weightless basically weightless
okay
[Music]
here we go
um 1905.
you should know immediately one thing
should know in your head 1905. einstein
comes out with this special theory of
relativity
okay that's right this is on fire
it's not what he called it it was the
paper that delivered it to us is called
on the electrodynamics of moving bodies
and no one wanted to recite that so just
called special relativity but that's
what it is because it's all about
the relativity of motion and time okay
so
what it did was codify
the fact
that
that spatial dimensions
need a for the three spatial dimensions
you know height width and depth need a
fourth dimension
to localize it in any
spatial system you're talking about
and since you needed time then it's a
space-time system
so
so
it sounds like it's weird like what are
you doing einstein you know leave me
alone with my height with and depth but
it turns out we have always thought
about life in four dimensions
[Music]
so you know the french came up with the
metric system did you know this no
wonder we don't use it
[Laughter]
so it got implemented in 1789 and what
was happening then
in france
1789.
yeah 89. in part inspired by what
happened in the united states uh was
that the best deal storming and all that
yeah
french revolution yeah right yeah so
part of that sort of overthrowing of all
previous order that was the occasion if
you're going to do it that's a good time
to do it right in addition to the
rolling heads you throw in the metric
system we need everywhere to figure
[Music]
[Laughter]
measure it in new way
[Music]
so you plug things into the wall
are you asking yourself
i wonder what kind of power this is
are you are you even wondering what it
cost you it's actually relatively cheap
all right relative i mean compared to
other things you spend money on it's
it's so cheap that if you're driving
away and you realize guys i left the
living room light on are you going to
stop the car turn around and go back and
turn out the light and then continue to
your dinner no you just say i'll turn it
off when i go
when i get home right that's how casual
we are about this so you plug it into
the wall
you don't know what produced that energy
it could be coal could be uh oil it
could be a hydro it could be solar
panels it could be nuclear it could be
tidal you don't know and in fact you
don't care
so
if laws change if we run out of oil if
we whatever goes on in the energy
marketplace
doesn't have to concern you
the power company says i will now
generate power from wind uh from from
solar
from from hydro by the way wind and
hydroelectric are both solar powered
right the sun evaporates ocean water and
that moves on land it comes out as rain
to some high lake you damn that or a
river you damn that and then you have
hydro power and of course wind powers
the uneven heating of earth's surface
causing wind movement so
so solar panels wind and hydro all solar
power okay so the the electric company
if the price of oil goes high let's swap
in more solar if we outlaw
coal they put bring in hydro by bringing
nuclear whatever else it is
they're not beholden to oil
to create power that comes out of your
wall socket
[Music]
when you're walking down the sidewalk
and you see a worm
do you pause and say gee i wonder what
that worm is thinking gee let me let me
let let me figure out how this works no
no you put it on a hook and you go get
dinner
so so just to believe that we are so
interesting that something as advanced
as a civilization with flying saucers to
cross the galaxy would sit there and
want to analyze us so so that's hubris
okay
uh so there's that but also
consider
uh how many
photographs
are taken every day
everybody's got a smartphone right
almost everybody high resolution
uh and if you're not taking a photo
you're taking a video
and so you if there's something unusual
and interesting you're taking a video of
that
we have video of stuff you never got
videos of before you'd think an alien
encounter would be rare
but you've got a smartphone and you can
stream it
in the old days when people said did you
take pictures of the alien that abducted
you yeah but they stole the film
or i got the film home and the whole
roll was blank because the alien zapped
it or whatever so
so it's a recording device but a
streaming device is not a recording
device so you can live stream whatever
is happening all right so so you would
expect given how many reports of
abductions there were right
of decades past
that somebody would have that on
you know that be posted by now and it
hasn't been
so this leads me to think strongly
that people's imaginations got the
better side of their life experience
when they came back to report on having
been abducted
[Music]
so
what's happening is
because you're getting spun you have an
urge to fly off
at a tangent of that circle
okay
that urge to fly off that is prevented
you will feel as a centrifugal force
okay okay so if in any moment
the walls just disappeared on the
cyclone at is it called the cyclone
whatever that was called out of the fly
i forget the name of it but i do
remember i think i'm missing remember
because cyclone is the roller coaster at
right at coney island at coney island so
whatever that thing is we've all done it
right and
if at any instant while that's spinning
the walls just disappeared
you would just fly off at a tangent
everybody would just fly off going in
exactly the tangential direction they
were going
right at the moment the walls
disappeared okay
lawsuit
lawsuit
[Music]
so in it comes particles in earth's
atmosphere
that happen to be the same size as the
wavelength of light
of the blue side of the spectrum the
blue indigo purple violet side of the
spectrum those particles
preferentially scatter the blue
[Music]
out of the sunlight
it preferentially scatters it so it
subtracts away a little bit just a
little bit
all right
the rest of the light makes it all the
way to earth's surface
but some of the blue gets scattered and
that's why we have a blue sky
nice the blue sky is stolen sunlight
that would have otherwise passed
straight through
look at that okay right because the sky
is really clear right
okay so now watch how beautiful is that
though now let's have the sun get a
little lower in the sky
well there'll be more of this going on
okay more of the scat that's why
on cloudless days into sunset the sun
gets deeper and deeper and deeper blue
[Music]
what i'm saying is
we monitor when we have fell behind a
second okay so when the second when we
know that we've lost a second based on
our atomic measurement correct then
internationally we say time to throw in
a leap second now
by convention we throw it in on june
30th or on december 31st and we can
throw in one at each time if we needed
it okay since
1973 or four or something like early 70s
there's been 23 24 leap seconds added to
the calendar sweet so when they're going
to add a leap second they choose which
of those days it will be when they do so
that final minute has 61 seconds in it
nice yes it's very cool that's very cool
and so so this is what we do that's the
longest minute of
yes it's the longest minute because it's
actually 61 seconds
okay so newspapers like having fun with
they say this year will be slightly
longer than other years right because
you have to throw in the leap second
that leap second happens on greenwich
time so for us it would take place at
like uh i guess 7 p.m right because
we're five hours
uh behind them so in the christmas mean
time right great time much
[Music]